the last part is to grab array it's a
bit fun so let's have a look at this put
it all together it all together I know
that there is going to be a domain
restriction like this I know that when I
went through this I was trying to find a
stationary point right and then I
determined the only possible station
point is not a stationary point I can't
put it all together right the domain
restriction tells me I'm gonna have some
asymptotes like so right I know this is
gonna be a point of inflection but then
you know what I don't know very much
else upon about this thing apart from
that right I actually need some inter
sense yeah I've got x equals negative 1
and it's 0 as my vertical asymptotes but
I kind of need to know where I collide
with the coordinate axes the x-axis of
this because you can see I don't collide
with the y-axis because of that nice
vertical asymptote so therefore to get
my x-intercepts what do I do
hello y equals 0 now when you look at
something like this it's a bit
intimidating because the fact that
there's a 1 in there right but don't be
afraid yeah when you put in 0 there I
have no space just yeah wait I should
solve it you're going to get log of that
equals 0 but remember this just means a
lot of messy right so therefore this
thing is e to the power of 0 which is 1
right so you get this being able to 1
and so you can multiply across merging
the X part equally
one and you just get a regular room for
trying to solve admittedly as you can
see by the coefficients it's more than
ice per credit you've gotta get back to
the folder again
but if I recall I think you get this as
your pair of roots right which is a
beautiful number now this okay so we've
got that
that's a cousin trigraph right actually
it's more useful to me to get some
decimal values for those because I have
no idea where they are
right so I think for remember we'll
actually have them I calculated right
now I've got minus point 6 1 8 as the
left-hand one and that would be it would
be 1.618 for the right-hand one okay now
- point six one eight is paralytic
illicit and I put your photos okay so
four terms and I know looking at this
I'm pretty much gonna put them one on
top of another right I'm going to get
something like
this might put a reflection right next
to it right and there's that intercept
that I got through solving this and then
never the right-hand side of 1.6 when I
move that's when 6 1 8 in 1.6 minute
review ok and you can check my signs
you're gonna get that kind of shader
there I just be ready get ready
I have 20 points anywhere there's no
other kind of unusual behavior over here
on the right so we ghouls cuz I already
determined yeah sure yeah with this
we're right at the edge of like when I
say right in this function is right at
the edge of what we can deal with in and
volleyball and the analytical in right
so for example okay something like this
right
this has a route I know it has at least
one or cubic curves have to have a roof
because they've got to start negative
and positive or vice versa
they've got to collide somewhere in
there because they're continuous
functions however I have no idea where
that route is and we can't remember I
establish before word we're talking
about some some products of roots etc
our roots and coefficients there's no
there's no cubic formula that's
practical for us to use here ok and that
doesn't mean I can't find roughly enough
to me grass where it collides are the
answers we're gonna learn those
techniques when we go into polynomials
ok what do you have a look at this I
mean you could different I mean we had
the derivative right right there okay so
I try to work out well what happens
between negative 1 & 0 put something
into this I could suffer value in and
that would tell me really quickly
because I know it's never going to turn
well let's just do this right so when x
equals negative ha
I'm just trying out a value that's I'm
fortunate company all those in a bit
we'll deal with it the derivative is
going to be equal to 1 and 1/2 on what
am I gonna get down here okay no I
actually don't care what the value is we
were trying to work out is it going up
or is it going down okay now you can see
here positive positive negative like
this is my factor thing right so it's
like up these positives terrific design
I've only got that one negative so that
tells me I have to be decreasing and I
never turn around I never ever turn
around so therefore he just goes down
all the way okay now that's a bit of a
it's a bit of a blunt instrument to used
but you like as
I just kind of had to pick a value but
based on everything I knew that's why I
to know if it goes down in that fashion
yes you can
so so what you could do am I asking like
you're trying to put values into PR is
that what you're suggesting if you want
to take limiting behavior
this is the reason why you can't do it I
guess you would do it with this but I
don't think it's any quicker or more
conclusive than what I did here right
for example if I put some values in I
would need to put at least like a couple
of values like I would expect I'll get
something negative but that doesn't mean
like it doesn't go long it just comes
from a really really negative - right
so whereas this tells me I'm decreasing
like that qualitatively tells me in that
little area I have to be going down and
I never turn around because I have no
stationary points okay something
probably that's the way that I would go
do you mean like do they coincide I
don't think so because this and this but
they're they're vanishingly close
together for purposes of my graph I
don't think I could I would never expect
a student to be able to distinguish like
sorry can someone just generate that
again ask someone to be accurate to be
yeah 2.04 of you know on the graph
that's a bit ridiculous so if someone do
that put in reflection while on top of
their the x-intercept I would
that's fine technically this question
can she use the second derivative now
you found that values say ah darn no no
no it's not enough because I can be what
we took it so for example I will
determine once I do my second review
test she I determined that I'm calling K
up and then concave down right but I can
increase or decrease over vegetable like
Nikki's were wondering do I start up
here you're down you in a vice versa
right I can still do the other way
knowing this right because I would draw
a graph something like this I would hit
that would do it yeah you're right
you're right but this for this
particular graph would be okay because
of these asymptotes that I have you we
don't have to collage ecology but I
think this is probably this is a more
direct way of saying oh it starts up
there and it goes down there because
that's what the gradient alright so any
other questions yeah that's good um yeah
so Jimmy the table values so often the
second derivative yes you can you can
however I don't know for me at least I
think that's less obvious I'm happy
feeling go with that obviously less work
I don't have to evaluate this thing but
for me like I don't I don't look at this
and say oh oh I must be pretty yeah but
that takes another step if you make that
step
is really obvious